Se ruoti una palla attorno a un asse e poi attorno a un altro, non è la stessa cosa che fare le due rotazioni nell'ordine inverso.
Oggi in Qiskit in the Classroom vedremo cosa ha a che fare questa palla con i computer quantistici e con uno dei più famosi
principi della meccanica quantistica: il principio di indeterminazione.
Benvenuto a Qiskit in the Classroom, una serie video dove analizziamo un concetto fondamentale che potresti
incontrare in un corso legato al Quantum Computing. Ogni video è accompagnato da un modulo interattivo linkato nella
descrizione qui sotto, quindi assicurati di dargli un'occhiata. Oggi parliamo del principio di indeterminazione di Heisenberg. Se
ne hai già sentito parlare, potresti aver sentito anche la vecchia barzelletta su Heisenberg: un giorno fu fermato dalla polizia mentre guidava e il poliziotto gli chiese: sa
a che velocità stava andando? Heisenberg rispose: no, ma so esattamente dove mi trovo. Questo è in qualche modo
il principio di indeterminazione di Heisenberg in poche parole: non puoi conoscere simultaneamente la posizione e la quantità di moto di una particella
con perfetta precisione. Viene spesso scritto così: Delta x per Delta p è maggiore
o uguale a ħ/2, dove Delta x e Delta p sono le
incertezze nella posizione e nella quantità di moto e ħ è una piccola costante fondamentale della meccanica quantistica.
Heisenberg formulò questa disuguaglianza nel 1927, quando stava immaginando come misurare la posizione di un elettrone. Se
fai rimbalzare un fotone su di esso per vedere dove si trova, quel fotone inevitabilmente dà un colpo all'elettrone e ne disturba la
quantità di moto. Questa non è solo un'affermazione sulle misurazioni che disturbano un sistema: ci dice che ci sono limiti fondamentali
a quanto possiamo imparare sulla natura. Questo è un esempio di un principio più ampio chiamato complementarità, che
dice che certi aspetti della natura sono incompatibili tra loro e non possono essere osservati
simultaneamente. Per esempio, gli oggetti quantistici a volte si comportano come particelle e a volte come onde,
ma non puoi osservare entrambi i comportamenti simultaneamente. La relazione di Heisenberg tra posizione e quantità di moto copriva solo una di
molte coppie di caratteristiche complementari. Questa incertezza intrinseca ha a che fare con il modo in cui vediamo proprietà come
posizione e quantità di moto nella meccanica quantistica. Invece di pensare a x e p come variabili o proprietà intrinseche
che ogni particella possiede, nella meccanica quantistica posizione e quantità di moto sono operatori. Non sono proprietà di un
sistema ma cose che puoi fare a un sistema. Apprendere la posizione di una particella ora richiede di eseguire un'operazione
su quel sistema ed effettuare una misurazione. Questa operazione potrebbe influenzare il risultato di altre operazioni
successive. Come analogia, pensa a un pezzo di legno secco. Ha molte proprietà come la sua
posizione, dimensione, forma. Ha anche la proprietà di essere bruciabile e di galleggiare in acqua. Se questo legno fosse un
oggetto quantistico, queste non sarebbero proprietà che potresti semplicemente conoscere a priori. Invece diciamo che sono
osservabili, cose che puoi apprendere sul sistema se esegui un'operazione su di esso. Quindi dovresti applicare l'operatore di
bruciabilità o di galleggiabilità, il che richiederebbe provare effettivamente a bruciare il legno o metterlo in
acqua per vedere se galleggia. Ora, il risultato di ciascuno di questi operatori dipende dall'ordine in cui li applichi. Se
prima testi la bruciabilità, il legno brucerà in cenere e non potrai testare se galleggia. Ma se testi la
galleggiabilità prima, sarà troppo bagnato per bruciare. Diciamo che gli operatori di bruciabilità e
galleggiabilità non commutano: l'ordine delle operazioni conta. Questo porta a un limite fondamentale
su quanto bene queste due osservabili possano essere conosciute riguardo al pezzo di legno, poiché non possiamo dire con certezza se è
bruciabile o galleggiabile senza conoscere il contesto di quella misurazione. Ora, ovviamente con un vero pezzo di legno potresti
tagliarlo a metà e testare entrambe le proprietà simultaneamente. Ma non puoi fare niente del genere con una particella quantistica. Questa
analogia con il legno è solo un'analogia. L'indeterminazione è qualcosa di unicamente quantistico. Anche x e p non commutano
e questa proprietà di non commutatività è ciò che porta al principio di indeterminazione di Heisenberg. In generale, due qualsiasi operatori
che non commutano avranno la propria relazione di indeterminazione. La forma generale del principio di indeterminazione può essere
scritta così: Delta a per Delta
b è maggiore o uguale a
1/2 per il valore di a e b dove
questa parentesi è chiamata il
commutatore ed è uguale alla differenza tra applicare prima a poi
b e applicare prima b poi a. Queste parentesi angolari
qui indicano che stai prendendo quello che si chiama il valore di aspettazione di ciò che c'è dentro. Fondamentalmente, se facessi la stessa
misurazione moltissime volte, il valore di aspettazione è il valore medio di tutte quelle misurazioni. Oggi andremo
effettivamente a testare e verificare questo principio di indeterminazione su un computer quantistico IBM. Esamineremo tre diversi
osservabili di un qubit, mostreremo che i loro operatori non commutano e infine potremo dimostrare che il
principio di indeterminazione vale per queste osservabili del qubit. Prima una breve parentesi su un modo utile per visualizzare lo stato
quantistico di un qubit. Può essere rappresentato da un vettore che punta verso un punto su una sfera chiamata sfera di Bloch. Ne ho parlato
in un video precedente che è linkato nella descrizione, ma ti darò anche un breve riepilogo qui. Ecco la
sfera di Bloch. Ogni vettore è parametrizzato da due angoli theta e phi.
Lo stato zero è al Polo Nord e lo stato uno è al Polo Sud e una sovrapposizione uguale di 0 e uno è
da qualche parte lungo l'equatore, dove phi è uguale alla fase relativa tra le due parti della
sovrapposizione. Quindi questo stato qui sarebbe uguale
a 1/radice di 2 per 0 più e alla i phi per 1, dove i è quella
fase. Quando misuriamo un osservabile del qubit, il risultato è sempre una di due opzioni corrispondenti ai due
possibili stati del qubit. Per l'esperimento che stiamo per fare guarderemo tre osservabili e
i loro operatori corrispondenti X, Y e Z. Quando misuri una qualsiasi di queste osservabili ottieni o più uno o
meno uno, con una probabilità per ciascuno che dipende dall'angolo tra il vettore del qubit sulla sfera di Bloch e
l'asse di misurazione. Come ci si aspetterebbe, Z misura lungo l'asse Z, X lungo X
e Y lungo Y. Ora ricorda che stiamo parlando di osservabili perché con un sistema
quantistico non possiamo più semplicemente conoscere le cose sul sistema senza misurarle.
E ogni osservabile ha un'operazione corrispondente perché le misurazioni richiedono operazioni. Potrebbe non essere ovvio, ma
risulta che le operazioni, chiamate operatori, che corrispondono a ciascuna di queste osservabili x, y e z sono
rotazioni di pi greco attorno ai rispettivi assi. Quindi X è una rotazione attorno a X, Y
attorno a Y e Z attorno a Z. Quindi per vedere se questi operatori commutano o no possiamo verificare se le rotazioni
su una sfera commutano. Se commutano, il principio di indeterminazione non si applicherà e potremmo conoscere X, Y e Z di un qubit
con perfetta precisione. Se non commutano, allora troveremo una nuova relazione di indeterminazione per il qubit. Osserva
il punto su questa palla mentre ruoto prima attorno a X e poi attorno a Y. Finisce
qui. Ora proviamo nell'ordine inverso: ruoto prima attorno a Y e
poi attorno a X. Finisce qui. Quindi decisamente non commutano. Ciò significa
che non possiamo conoscere simultaneamente i valori esatti di X, Y e Z di un qubit e avremo una
relazione di indeterminazione. Sorvoleremo sui dettagli qui, ma finiamo con tre diverse relazioni
di indeterminazione. Abbiamo Delta x per Delta Y
maggiore o uguale a Z, Delta Y per Delta Z maggiore o uguale
a X, e Delta Z per Delta X maggiore o uguale
a Y. Quindi il prodotto di due qualsiasi di queste incertezze è sempre maggiore o
uguale al valore di aspettazione della terza osservabile. Usiamo Qiskit per vedere cosa
succede quando proviamo a misurare sia Z che X dello stato zero. Misurare Z è facile: è la cosiddetta base standard
del computer quantistico, le misurazioni sono sempre lungo Z per impostazione predefinita. Ma per misurare X dobbiamo eseguire qualcosa chiamato
cambio di base, fondamentalmente ruotando la sfera di Bloch in modo che X ora punti verso l'alto dove prima puntava Z. Per fare questo
usiamo una gate Hadamard. Quindi il circuit quantistico completo apparirà così: misuriamo in Z, applichiamo la Hadamard
e poi misuriamo in X. Se usiamo la primitiva sampler di Qiskit per eseguire questo esperimento molte volte, finiamo
con un istogramma dei risultati di misurazione che appare così per la misurazione
in Z e così per la misurazione in X. Come puoi vedere, abbiamo misurato il
qubit nello stato zero lungo Z con quasi il 100% di certezza, ma
lungo X non sapevamo praticamente nulla sullo stato del qubit. È stato misurato come zero o uno con uguale
probabilità, il che significa che la nostra incertezza in X era circa la massima possibile. Questo ci dà
un'idea di questo compromesso tra incertezze. Ma possiamo fare un po' meglio: sul nostro computer quantistico possiamo usare una
primitiva di Qiskit chiamata estimator per trovare i valori di aspettazione delle nostre osservabili X, Y e Z e
l'incertezza in ciascuna. Proviamolo per lo stato che punta nella direzione più X sulla sfera di Bloch. Useremo l'estimator
per calcolare le incertezze in x e z per questo stato e il valore di aspettazione di
y. Con questo stato otteniamo questo risultato da Qiskit. Quando prendiamo il prodotto delle due
incertezze in x e y vediamo che, come previsto, è maggiore del valore
assoluto del valore di aspettazione di y. Ma questo era solo per uno stato particolare. Vogliamo assicurarci che questa disuguaglianza
valga per tutti gli stati del qubit. Quindi usiamo di nuovo l'estimator, ma stavolta gli chiederemo di scansionare i valori di un
parametro e trovare i valori di aspettazione per ogni singolo valore del parametro che gli diamo. Qui il parametro che vogliamo
scansionare è l'angolo theta sulla sfera di Bloch, in modo da verificare la disuguaglianza per tutti gli stati del qubit che giacciono su
questo arco che interseca il piano XZ. Quando lo facciamo, otteniamo un grafico in funzione dell'angolo theta. La curva
rossa è il prodotto delle due incertezze e la curva arancione è il valore di aspettazione di y. Come previsto,
il prodotto delle incertezze in x e z è molto più alto del valore di aspettazione di y. Ma non è stato
troppo difficile soddisfare la disuguaglianza perché il valore di aspettazione di y era così basso: era zero per tutti gli stati su
questo arco. Facciamo una scansione simile dei valori di theta ma invece di scansionare nel piano XZ, poniamo phi uguale a pi/
4, così guardiamo gli stati del qubit che giacciono su un arco diverso sulla sfera. Qui vediamo che la disuguaglianza è
messa più alla prova poiché la curva arancione e la curva rossa sono più vicine tra loro, ma la rossa è sempre sopra l'arancione
e il principio di indeterminazione vale ancora. Non abbiamo controllato tutti gli stati ancora, ma speriamo che tu stia iniziando a capire
il concetto: c'è un'inconoscibilità fondamentale su due aspetti complementari qualsiasi di un sistema
quantistico, compreso questo qubit che abbiamo usato. Il principio di indeterminazione ci costringe ad affrontare il fatto che non importa
quanto ci proviamo, non importa quanto siano intelligenti le nostre misurazioni, non conosceremo mai tutto con perfetta precisione.
Non c'è modo di aggirarlo, davvero. Se non mi credi, o anche se mi credi, ti sfido: vai a controllare il modulo
linkato nella descrizione e prova a battere il principio di indeterminazione. Grazie per aver guardato e ci vediamo la prossima volta.